you know what you're looking at that's
the emerald theater in mount clemons
michigan there's a reason why we're
showing you that picture this early
morning
in michigan welcome back to cbs this
morning president trump won michigan by
a razor thin margin that was back in
2016
and both the president and joe biden are
now focused on turnout there
this election michigan is one of the
three crucial battleground states
tony is visiting this week for our
series we're calling it
at america's crossroads so he's been
traveling in an rv
to meet real live voters who could
decide this election and now just over
two weeks 15 days and counting
let's go back to tony in mount clemens
michigan that's why we showed you the
theater that's outside detroit
tony good morning again to you hey good
morning guys i should say we are
traveling in the rv but not sleeping in
the rv so i arrived pretty put together
this morning and i've got an interesting
fact for you
most people in michigan woke up unhappy
about the results of the 2016 election
of course
that is at least according to their
votes now how do i know well because
donald trump won here with only
47 percent support that's a minority in
an election where hundreds of thousands
of people
cast their ballot for a third party
candidate or did not
vote at all so now democrats including
michigan governor gretchen whitmer
are focused on two things turning out
voters in detroit
and winning the suburbs for joe biden
hi michigan governor gretchen whitmer
spent part of this past weekend going
door to door
health care for all is very important to
me with dog treats in her pocket
it's a little treat hearing from voters
in oakland county michigan
what is the most important thing the
pandemic i'm a physician
and the handling of the pandemic has
been horrific
it's part of a get out the vote effort
in a ring of crucial suburban areas
surrounding detroit
and a sign of how competitive this race
has become until this month the biden
campaign and put a coronavirus related
pause on door knocking
while the trump campaign had not they're
very proud of their ground game they say
they've been knocking on doors long
before you guys started doing this
i can't tell you what they've been doing
i can tell you we've been taking this
pandemic seriously
the biden campaign also seriously knows
it needs to do better here than hillary
clinton did four years earlier
losing by the thinnest margin of any
state less than 11
000 votes so what's your theory of what
happened in 2016
why did turnout fall from 2012 for the
democrats
michiganders did not come out and vote i
mean it was a historically low election
yeah donald trump won with a with a
minority he only got 47
or so we don't have tidal waves here in
michigan but i do think that this
year is going to dwarf anything we've
ever seen and i think that bodes well
for
joe biden and i think it bodes well for
michigan donald trump has been
not knocking on doors but at his rallies
bringing up the suburbs all the time
yeah we saved suburbia in the u.s
he says he saved the suburbs suburbs
like these
these suburbs didn't need to be safe
though and the people who call these
suburbs home
cares much about equity care as much
about
ensuring every child has a path to a
good education they care
about every family being able to drink
their water and about climate change so
those those dog whistles
don't really land when you're really
talking to voters here
40 minutes away in detroit michigan's
republican chairwoman laura cox says a
few gubernatorial door knocks this late
in the election
is no match for the gop's turnout
operation the campaign claims to have
knocked on a million doors in michigan
alone
we're in a great place we're going to
win again for the president the vice
president
the enthusiasm is palpable
but we noticed a different kind of
enthusiasm scrawled across the wall of
the gop's black voices headquarters here
when you talk about enthusiasm or
emotion here
what does that graffiti tell you it
tells me that we're getting under their
skin and our messages are resonating
and they're worried detroit is the
largest majority black city in america
and perhaps the biggest single reason
donald trump triumphed in michigan in
2016.
hillary clinton won the county by a
landslide but with 76 thousand
fewer votes than barack obama which is
why we stopped by a voter registration
event hosted by detroit action
a community group trying to bring more
voters to the polls
that's where we found musician mike
phelps who says last election he didn't
even bother with voting
didn't see the point where were you in
2016 at home
america has had a history of promising
change to certain groups
and them never seeing that change now he
says the stakes are clear
and not only to him all of my friends
who never really get into politics
are all all in it right now they're
going to vote they register
they're voting for home voting at the
polls like i've seen a lot more
excitement
mike phelps is a very interesting guy in
fact very talented musician we were
almost late for our conversation with
gretchen whitmer because we hung around
to watch him
finish his set there the other thing i'd
add about mr phelps is he really
represents
what could be a turning point in this
election he says it's not that the
president
has affected his life but he's become
very aware guys about how
the president has affected other
people's lives that has woken
up him up that's why he's going to the
polls if other people have that same
realization
we could see a landslide in one
direction or another here
in 2020. yeah yeah tony listen people
are enthusiastic on both sides is what
i'm finding i don't care
that's right and the early voting
numbers are astonishing
i do wish every time i hear the
president say i've saved the suburbs i
always wish he would finish that
sentence
save the suburbs from what i always want
to know what's the last part of that
sentence
save the suburbs from what all right
tony doesn't have an answer i'm not sure
i can't read his mind
exactly i'm not trying to put you on the
spot tony or even asking you to finish
the sentence
that's what everybody goes say this and
it's crickets nobody can finish it
thank you tony to cover